on se trouve ici à lille devant les
locaux de l'association magdala une
association qui vient en aide aux plus
démunis et notamment aux mal logés
c'est quoi être mal logés concrètement
être mal logés concrètement je pense que
c'est habiter dans un logement où on n'a
pas forcément l'eau chaude être dans un
logement qui est envahi par les souris
par exemple être dans un logement qui
est sale qui a été loué salle ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas des bailleurs
sociaux mais qui est plus le cas des
rivières des bailleurs privés
malheureusement et d'être en train dans
un logement très exigu trop petit voilà
je pense que c'est ça être mal logés
dans les locaux de l'association nous
avons rencontré emmanuel après avoir
connu la rue et grâce à la vie
associative
il a trouvé un logement décent j'en suis
content et voilà encore parce que le
monde de la russe et c'est très dur
moralement et physiquement aussi
ça vous n'auriez pas pu le trouver tout
seul non non je pense pas étant donné
que quand on fait maintenant une demande
d'appartements social comme hlm tout ce
qui est et les matchs ou partie nord est
où il ya des années il y en a il ya là
ils mettent des années à à vous fournir
à l'appartement que même en ce qui
concerne un studio quoi bonjour nadine
c'est à quel étage
maintenant je paye normalement avec
l'apl je paie normalement 450 euros
c'est un propriétaire privé
ça fait un nom suisse yeux c'est par
loeb qui viennent les souris passe par
un sou de la douchette ah ouais comme
menacée voilà c'est comme ça c'est un ca
libre et qu'est-ce qui vous répond votre
propriétaire quand vous lui parlez des
problèmes de votre appartement ben mon
propriétaire r'n'b exactement qu'il peut
pas faire les travaux c'est pas un mois
c'est pas lui de les faire
j'ai rien accepter qu'en côte-d'or type
aussi en france quand même corps en 2018
selon la fondation abbé pierre dans les
hauts de france près de deux cent mille
logements étaient considérés comme
potentiellement indignes
[Musique]